One of the things you can be virtually
certain of in life is that you don't get
something you don't aim at,
and one of the things that's interesting
about that is often people will keep
their goals fuzzy because one of the
problems with specifying your goals as
you specify your failures,
right?
If the goal is really fuzzy,
you're not sure when you fail and that
then you can fool yourself.
You know,
really,
but you can kind of keep it foggy,
but you make your goal sharp and clear,
then well,
first of all,
then you know what to aim at.
And what's interesting is you know your
brain is set up so that it reorganizes
the world around your aims.
And that's not.
I've also written about this and 12
rules for life quite extensively,
and that's not a.